our deputy political editor sam coats
joins me now he has some breaking news
relating to
russia and interference in uk politics i
think
sam yes the government have just
published a written
ministerial statement about the events
around
last year's general election and an
allegation a claim that the government
is today making about the uh parts of
the conduct
around that election now you might
remember adam that in the middle of the
campaign
jeremy corbyn brandished elite document
a u.s uk trade
document showing the discussions between
the two countries about the state of the
trade negotiations
now the allegation being made in this
written
ministerial statement today is that
russian
actors so that's not the government
that's just somebody
uh connected to the russian state was
involved
and uh here's the critical word in
amplifying
uh that report uh effectively to make
sure
that it got uh noticed in other words
russian actors were
uh i think you can think of it as sort
of pushing it around the internet
uh the implication being to try and make
sure it played a role
uh in the general election campaign
presumably to try and sow
discord perhaps between the uk and the
u.s because there were sensitive details
of
the trade negotiations in that and also
potentially to put the conservatives on
the back foot which is very much what
labour tried to do
uh with that now it's important to note
what this written ministerial statement
doesn't say it doesn't say that the
russian state or russian actors
actually acquired this leaked document
apparently it was already on the
internet
uh but just in a sort of unloved corner
of the internet uh when uh uh uh when
the russian actors found it and they
said just just briefly we've got to see
this in the context of the
uh russia report from the intelligence
committee being published which is about
uh the period before the general
election uh covering
uh of course the referendum and this
looks a bit like a preemptive strike
uh by the government against what that's
going to reveal yeah well we were always
expected to be talking about british
politics in relation to russia over the
next few days but just not quite like
this
because as you're saying uh in the next
few days we're going to get the report
into
uh potentially touri links uh in uh with
uh russians in the coming days but here
we have i think what the government
hopes are questions for labour to answer
about the links with russia